ils sont petits maniables très efficaces
et c'est une arme majeure de la guerre
en Ukraine sont les drones la Russie et
l'Ukraine les utilise en nombre dans ce
conflit pour Moscou c'est un outil de
bombardement des infrastructures
ukrainiennes plus d'une dizaine d'entre
eux ont été abattus ces derniers jours
par la défense antiérienne ukrainienne
qui Ève de son côté les utilise vous
allez le voir pour des opérations de sa
bon de sabotage près de la frontière Luc
Lacroix pour France 2
des drones russes
qui s'envolent pour le ciel
ukrainien
l'image fait les titres de la télévision
russe elle prétend qu'il cible des
infrastructures la nuit dernière les
forces russes ont lancé une attaque de
drone massive sur des cibles
industrielles et militaires sur le
territoire de l'Ukraine
selon les Ukrainiens ils visaient en
fait la capitale Kiev où ils ont été
intercepté et Odessa dans le sud presque
au même moment à hilski côté russe la
raffinerie prend feu là encore il
s'agirait d'une attaque de drone cette
fois ukrainien et ce soir le gouverneur
de Sébastopol en Crimée écrit sur son
compte télégram qu'un drone aurait été
éliminé à proximité d'un aéroport
plus que jamais ce conflit est d'abord
une guerre des drones depuis des mois la
ligne de front était figée mais le front
se ranime et le bilan de la guerre
s'alourdit hier scène de panique à la
gare et dans un supermarché de Herson
dans le sud de l'Ukraine
ils ont été touchés par des tirs
d'artillerie
il y a eu des éclats de métal qui
venaient du toit de la fumée partout la
panique
selon les Ukrainiens 21 personnes ont
perdu la vie 46 ont été blessés les
Russes n'ont fait aucun commentaire
officiel
monter de l'attention des deux côtés les
armées entraînent leur soldats dans
l'urgence
une contre-offensive ukrainienne est
annoncée comme imminente mais sur leur
chemin les Ukrainiens trouveront les
fortifications construites par les
Russes elles atteindraient 800 km de
long selon certaines estimations